[Applause]
this
first son oh you like that one yeah
andrew knows my first yeah i know where
yeah how's the amber bro
it blew my mind what oh dove has always
[ __ ] way hotter girls not even just
that she's hot but it's like oh
i that girl is everywhere yeah that's it
you know he's a lovely person this guy
i honestly it don't make any sense he's
like a jewish joshua cardo you're just
getting just you went real specific with
that
just for you literally just for me
nobody else could know it's just just
for you
but dove has been batting out of his uh
his league is that the word yeah out
kicking his coverage out kicking his
coverage
the entire time i've known him it is
unbelievable you you would not
believe how hot the girls that dove
[ __ ]
are to the point where i've had on
multiple occasions asks if he pays to
[ __ ] this
i've been like how is it possible we're
talking about like
ten tens and dove is a very charming guy
he's very funny guy
yeah right but he looks like he could be
selling bread in morocco
right like he's not but still pulling
while selling bread exactly
unbelievable no i don't see that second
part i see the bread
[Laughter]
unbelievable i couldn't i cannot believe
i it's
i'm baffled by it it blew my mind
have you seen it happen no i want it
well he knows there's one there's also
one's in the sports world andrew do they
know about the one in the sports world
who's the one in the sports world
no he's he was jealous
but remember miss alabama no
remember the girl that was featured
during the bcs bowl the
and the announcer was like oh yeah brett
musburger
it was the alabama national championship
and he was being like mad creepy about
this hot girl in the audience who's like
some
it was something catherine webb and aj
mccarron yeah they're happily married
with the kids
she is i mean daddy who was the who was
the the boy before that
you know you'd be getting these girls
she came up before they come up
yeah yeah i think i'm good luck chuck
believe me like after me they
really go places yeah you don't glow up
after you get done
what is the trick man what are you doing
bro you gotta adapt
if if if you're charming and you see
that they think you're charming go with
that
if they're annoyed by you keep talking
their ear off until they just give up
and they're like all right fine i'll
give you that chance and never feel like
you're getting turned down
so it is unbelievable i've seen him go
through like hell he was just like i
feel like yeah if they hate you you just
keep talking
they'll love you bro it is i'm not
questioning
i don't i believe you i'm just like my
mind is not understanding
how that works there's no way you can
can never get turned down
you there's there's a way school the
audience buddy because this is
fascinating
i'm just saying it's like not do she
pick up artists it's like a non-douchey
pickup artist where it's like
you go with the
make them think like they just met like
oh if not oh he's a nice guy he's my
friend
i can always dial it back to there and
then i'm like all right if i got
i got to play a longer game in this but
they'll come around
by the way what andrew knows is you i'll
get them the first night or
six months later but six months later
they'll fall in love with me like they
never had a love like that but you have
to describe the 49
gay thing oh also with these girls if
they say no you would like leave them
alone right
leave them alone but they come back you
you know
like what are you doing bro he's trying
to give you
coverage and the worst case scenario is
like i tee up andrew or i
i'm out used to bro don't get me what
you should do
you used to do the classic opener no the
okay so i so part of dove's game is
pretending to be gay not pretending
i just understand them okay what does
that mean
it's unbelievable no no no no no it's
unbelievable bro
this is fascinating unbelievable i want
to spend time on this go go go
look i don't know if he's gay or not
until there's something
they're sucking his dick and he's like
complimenting the tracks in their hair
like oh girl you killing him with that
hair
i like your barrettes those extensions
are crazy is that crimp
so they have to understand the
background it's like as many friends
like andrew i had i grew up in a house
my parents are fashion designers so i
knew the fashion game my sis i have two
sisters a year older you're younger oh
let's
learn everything real quick we're gonna
get back to another thing that he does
like
you know how like mark is filled with
like useless knowledge about like um
like science yeah so like mark
dove is is the same but about girls
but since mark never [ __ ] he didn't
need to know about girl [ __ ]
so dove has all that like he'll walk up
to a girl and he'll like smell her and
he'll be like
oh is that a job
dude that [ __ ] truffle can take down
any perfume
there's about 12 15 perfumes in the
library and most girls
80 i would say 80 percent of girls
probably use one of 10 to 15 perfumes
and i could call these things out and
whatever reason it's just like
that becomes an opener so so it's
unbelievable so it's like
you've never seen it happen and he'll
find one little thing like uh a girl
will be like
yeah i'm actually from santorini and
he'll be like
and she's like i'll do nobody like he'll
know one
useless thing about everything in the
world what useless and he'll be able to
oh yeah of course and there's a little
french restaurant by the with the little
crostinis
oh my favorite place with the crostinis
the best crostini
in the game no wisdom sure facts that
start the process start the conversation
the process
he starts to wear on you after a while
but they don't know
person he said he wanted to like oh i
was trying to [ __ ] her for so long
i was just like you're out shut the [ __ ]
up oh no no no
saying the names of just like these
people you're looking at dove you're
like
stop feeding me [ __ ] like you don't
have any chance with this girl
unbelievably real
and then you see who he actually [ __ ]
and you're like that's unbelievable
it's unbelievable he's unbelievable what
dove does with girls you do it comedy
it's like you just know something about
every [ __ ] culture it just
blows people's minds exactly i should
have been focused on [ __ ] perfume
[ __ ] just learn a few of those yeah he's
gonna chop
dog real talk dude so he'll do all these
little things on
all these little he'll know like nail
color like he'll be like a specific
color
if it's like a super dark purple you and
i will go with the girl we'll be like
like oh i like that you got some red
right yeah and dove will go like this
he'll be like
[Laughter]
[Music]
for the girls listening they'll be like
yup that's an actual real color
it's getting in the wide what does it
looks like
another thing is um no shame
will talk to anybody any girl doesn't
matter the situation
shame no shame and also like when he
approaches them it's kind of like funny
it's not they don't even know they're
really being approached yeah cause you
don't see that's why i never feel like
i'm getting turned down
and they don't see it coming yeah oh
i guess they think you're gay yes it's
okay but you don't understand transition
it's okay because they slowly realize
i don't need to tell them they will
slowly realize
oh [ __ ] he's not gay he's not a brad
chad
like bro-y guy he knows everything i
like did i just fall in love
like i'm telling you so what is a girl's
biggest like um
fear if you will and i'm not talking
about real fear like their life but like
what is their biggest like
obstacle when meeting a person right
like they'll get murdered or something
well
i think that's like the real crazy ones
but if it's an average guy it's like
he's gonna try to [ __ ] me and i just
don't want to be bothered oh yeah he
wants something from me
yeah and i think dove presents in such a
mysterious way
because he's so non-threatening he's
funny he can talk about anything but
like
the girl doesn't pick up on that he's
trying to [ __ ] me vibe
so there's no threat and she actually
kind of like i don't know it's all
what's it called what is it uh you have
your arm you have your defenses down
your shields are all down
so then she actually starts talking
that's her guard down the guard is down
if you were like a super good looking
dude you would probably do worse for
girls i have a super cool looking dude
i've got languages in my arse and i got
a whole lot
of good looking makes you do gorgeous yo
what's the best part about best looking
part about you
hold darkness if you close your eyes i'm
[Applause]
beautiful